sofort los gehe mit dem video möchte ich
mal kurz erklären was gleich passiert
weil es ihm nicht so gut rübergekommen
ist und zwar spielen ich und max
abwechseln pixel games und es geht darum
wer die meisten kills und da geht es
einmal darum wer die meisten kirchen
einer einzelnen runde holt und dann geht
es darum wer in den drei runden die er
spielt zusammen die meisten kfz dass wir
am ende zusammengerechnet damit es
verglichen und da nicht heraus weil der
krasseste player aller zeiten ist auf
jeden fall viel spaß mit dem wir hier
und wir sehen in welchen petronas planen
pro ausgesucht hier robert ab
gut sehr gut was ich dass man drei kids
123 also bester wert von 100 euro
erhalten gleichgezogen gleichgezogen
davos es geht und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge und so haben uns etwas
ganz besonders ausgabe kriegsbeginns und
das heutige handicap wirtschaft merkels
ich ging max ich fange an
und wer mehr kraft hat gewonnen dann
wird spielen hier auf der map den ruhm
und die ist immer ziemlich hektisch
plötzlich dass darüber zu gehen darum
gestritten
ich glaube du findest kein schwert
bitten ein alter wenn ich jetzt keine
schelte parameter also wir machen
einfach so ein franchise wer von uns
beiden merkels schafft also wir wechselt
einfach ab je nachdem wie viel zeit wir
haben machen wir unterschiedlich viele
runden ich habe so eine kleine
strichliste und da mache ich für jeden
kind schlief vielleicht gibt es schon
erste psp höchstwahrscheinlich sogar
zwei kirche so waren sehr gut aber ich
werde natürlich und es weitergehe
bersten
also schauen vielleicht machen wir
vielleicht machen wir beide zwei runden
vielleicht aber auch mehr einen strich
krieg wieder komplett
dass die quellen ein mein gott oh mein
gott oh mein gott oh mein gott ich muss
renz muss denn ein start kommt schon
mein auto und aufpassen musste dieser
seite ist nur die nase ist ein bisschen
kitzeln baby dass ich deine nase kitzelt
ruby eine geile oder ist sie das easy
bitte komm springen heute genau live ich
bin mit trader.ch der vier christa alter
das wäre mich an die legionäre
krankhafter 64 15 ps gemachte 53 hat
sich die nicht hier nicht aufgegeben hat
eine schlacht geht auf und geht
draufgehen es doppeldeutig leute wer
hätte es gedacht aber ich finde diese
checks richtig geil max hat immer so
keine ideen und am krater für mich lange
lange 500 euro da schon ein halbes jahr
zeit einen kenner sehen wir uns noch
einen kurzen kopf wieder frei aber du
bist jetzt könnten heute ist er wieder
und für allerdings gefragt warum wir
kannten wir müssen unter einem stark
umstellen weil ich habe sprinten auf
shift und nicken auf steuerung sprinten
auf steuerung uns liegen auf shift
könnte man die kommentare schreiben die
ihr das macht pro kiste größte ideal du
kriegst krieg ist ja kein startverbot
das in schweizer betten fertig zum
anderen ist es ihm an der jade kanal
kann an dem alles schwerter nein nein
aber aufheben des sk der bastard gott ja
ja komm komm raus ganz elementare sind
auch jedoch einfach drauf da schon die
erste fakten rex gründer kevin hatte ok
meine ist es sollte aber wird auch mal
wieder und der spaß die macht als strafe
für alle diese hülle gestanden haben es
geht darum dass einer die meisten kills
geschafft als wenn ich die runden
zusammen gerechnet sondern die runde mit
den meisten kills zählen mach es einfach
so viele versuche bis einer ja dann eine
box runde hat und ich würde sagen das
ist ein guter trasse vorteil für mich
das wasser vorteil für mich dass max
jetzt eine kurze runde gehabt hat weil
da kann ich meine jetzt wieder machen
und lachen und dann hat er keine mehr
also wieder so hatte sich wieder
umstellen es hat bis kurz gesehen hat
gesehen wir unsere tastenbelegung ist
stalking stalking wenn
ich bin in der besten position hier oben
online du kleines stück dreck ja ja ja
erster kerstin sprite reagieren die
einzelnen kills nehmen gerade als ich
anders eigentlich
wir müssen uns auch darauf einigen
action und konnten macht machen wir ein
macher einzelne kind hast überhaupt
keine chance also bisher ist die beste
rolle 4 kids von mir der übrigens auch
viel für deine karte
und jetzt mal direkt weiter
du bist in deiner karriere ausgegangen
sechs gespielten sekunden gespart nicht
wenig aber welche ist ganz klar pixel es
geht natürlich unterwegs ist entdeckt
hat die yamaha sie einfach alle sind
manchmal ist das leben ist ungerecht und
man aber keine waffe tiger das einfach
ihr schlagt mich nicht hast spaß jetzt
ein anderer drauf der anfang und der
sieht einfach die hacker also sicher und
es hat einfach paisley druck oder
zumindest sagen
denn eigentlich hugo diesen dem
schulsektor man kann nicht spielen
sondern mahnen und was immer noch kein
jugendwoche sich so einfach ist eine
schande sind geschichten aus dem leben
scheint über die haut nah kommt ihn
bitte nicht auseinander kriegs afrika
ist ein echt heftig ich meine absicht so
programmiert aber ich hab s spiel
programmiert wo ich damit sagen
euro pro lauf lauf wie einfach hinter
sie schaut man ein konzept sehen uns
wieder kommen immer er kommt immer ich
werde immer so oft dran kommen wie
kommst du immer im amt so lange wie
diese runde geht wenn jetzt zehn minuten
klar dass eine runde mehr so ferne mit
schreib mir die kommentare was fair ist
auch nicht
also danke danke
wir machen eine zusammenfassung die
befindet in der dritten runde
ok ich hab' kleinen vorteil weil ich
gerade schon in die dritte gespielt
haben du kannst du mir mal die die
kinder übersicht durch sein also eine
neue idee ein kürzlich seine idee aber
insgesamt
ich hab' ich habe sechs skills du hast
null erwartet man sich jetzt die jetzt
kommt die dritte runde 100 wir sehen uns
nach einem kettchen wieder manche sind
einfach zwei wertungen weißen kindes in
einer runde und klar wieso das ist das
realistisch ist allerdings dass die
wählerliste realität so hat er sich
wieder und die entscheidung ist gefallen
macht aber zwei wertungen oder was für
eine entscheidungs hast du dein herz
ich habe entschieden also ich habe die
entscheidung gefällt samstag und zwar
nach mit zwei wertungen einmal geld man
die meisten kids in einer runde geholt
hat und dann weißt du was ist mir echt
zu blöd jetzt ich meine idee ist ja
kommt greift mit der anfang einer
richtig begonnen der ich gesagt okay
leute es ist wirklich nicht mehr
feierlich da draußen ist wahrscheinlich
die leute mit ihren 1000 schwertern
unter die pilger ist es aber auch nestlé
pro ausgesucht hier wollt jetzt erst
recht ist sehr gut sehr gut was ich das
an drei kids den 123 also bester wert
pro runde wand worauf er hat und
gleichgezogen gleichgezogen
noch eine runde nein nein nein
bis heute hätte sich maria stopp lasten
dollar
du sagst wb.com und erstmals zusammen
also bei myspace pro runde stets viel zu
vier unentschieden meisten kids
insgesamt 6 4 gewonnen von mir schreibt
in die kommentare ob wir mehr davon
haben wollt also uns jetzt richtig spaß
natürlich sehr simpel
es wird zeit dass wir einen wie gesagt
schreib mir kommentar wenn der vorteil
das leck